-You know
our first guest tonight
from films such as "Hustlers"
and "Crazy Rich Asians"
and shows like
"Fresh Off the Boat"
and "The Terminal List."
Her book, "Making a Scene"
is on sale now,
and she stars in
"Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile,"
which is in theaters everywhere
this Friday.
Please welcome back to the show,
Constance Wu, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello, Constance!
-Hi!
-I'm so happy you're back.
-You know, I didn't know Fred
was here, and I have
to just tell Fred --
-Please.
-When I first booked
my first network sitcom,
"Fresh Off the Boat,"
I had no experience with comedy,
so I said,
"I gotta study somebody."
And you are who I studied
to learn how to be funny.
-Aww.
-How'd I do?
-That's so nice.
-I did!
-Thank you very much.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Now, knowing Fred,
he's gonna ask for a commission,
now that you've said that.
-$400 a month, in installments.
-Ooh! It paid off.
-Learn from the best.
-So this is a book of
personal essays.
-Yes.
-Which must have been,
I would imagine, challenging,
cathartic to write?
You talk about how acting
came to you very young.
-Mm-hmm.
-You share a photo.
You were the Mole in
"Wind in the Willows"?
-Yes, my first leading role.
-This is
your first leading role.
Look at you.
A very convincing mole.
-The Jeremy Strong of moles.
-[ Laughter ] Yeah. You lived
like a mole for a whole...
-No, if you look at
that picture, I mean it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like, I'm seriously a mole.
-Yeah!
It seemed like that
your drama teacher
saw some real talent in you.
-Yes, Mr. Frazel.
-But also was supportive of you.
You talk about the fact that
you were accused of plagiarism
in school.
-Yes, during 8th grade,
which I think is such
a pivotal year for kids,
I had
my Western Civilization teacher
accuse me of plagiarism,
and she had no proof,
so she made me go up to
all of my other teachers
and she said, "Do you think
Constance is good enough
to have written this?"
And every teacher said no.
-Oh, my God!
-Sorry, it makes me cry, even
thinking about it still.
But the only teacher who
said I wrote it
was my drama teacher,
Mr. Frazel,
and he said,
"Of course she wrote it."
It's funny, I had been, like,
so focused on the pain
of that story,
it wasn't until I wrote it
in my book that I realized.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
No wonder I ended up
being an actor."
Like, my drama teacher,
Mr. Frazel,
was the only one
who believed in me.
-Yeah, that's really amazing
to have someone supportive
like that.
-Yeah.
-He was like,
"Would a plagiarist
make a mole this good?"
[ Laughter ]
He was like,
"I'll tell you this,
there's not a single other
kid in this school
that could have been
a mole like her!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's the truth.
-So another thing
you write about
which received
quite a lot of attention
when it first happened,
which is,
you were on a show,
"Fresh Off the Boat."
It got renewed, which I think
for most actors,
is a really exciting thing.
And then you publicly sort of
basically shared
that you were upset that it was
coming back for another year.
You received a lot of
criticism for that,
especially from
people in the business
who would say things like,
"How could an actor ever be
upset their show got picked up
for another year?"
And so in this book,
you shared what happened,
which is, you were being
sexually harassed
by a senior producer.
Was it important for you to give
that context
as to what you were feeling
when you went through that
other public moment?
And how has the response been
for you?
-Well, to be honest, I didn't
want to write about that.
That was the last essay
I wrote for the book,
and only after being, like,
pushed by my editor,
like,
"You should write about this.
This is what people
want to hear."
And I was like, I'm done with
that chapter in my life.
Because all of the
sexual harassment,
the inappropriate touching,
the telling me to
wear short skirts
and intimidation,
that all only happened in
the first two years of the show
when I was still very scared
that I --
You know, I had never done
anything big before.
I had just graduated from
being a waitress,
and I was scared of being fired.
Once I felt a little bit
of job security,
then I started saying no
to this producer,
which infuriated him,
but it was okay.
So I thought, you know what?
I handled it.
I don't need to stay in
the reputation of this show
or of this producer.
I can just keep it inside.
And as a result, I feel like
I was never able to
really be myself on set,
'cause I'd see my abuser being
buddy-buddy with everybody else,
knowing what he had done to me.
And, you know,
the thing I learned is that
bad feelings and abuse
don't just go away
because you will it to.
It's gonna come out somewhere.
And so I think -- I mean,
people didn't understand
the context of those tweets.
Um...
And thank you for
not making fun of it,
because it led me to
a really dark time.
And so I think I decided
to include -- sorry --
I decided to include it
in the book because, um,
I think it's important that we
engage in curiosity and empathy
before we go straight
to judgement.
Because if somebody
does something
out of character for them,
usually something's going on
in their life.
Sorry!
-No, that's alright.
[ Applause ]
-It's really great
that you shared it.
-Yeah?
-And let me just say,
I think it's really special
not just that you gave context,
but also, it's really important
to share, like
people have jobs to do, right?
And they go to their jobs,
and those jobs,
that should be the hard part, is
doing the job every day.
The extra thing you had to do,
that was an incredibly
unfair burden.
-And it was before
the Me Too movement, too,
so I was just like,
"Nobody's gonna believe me,"
except for my middle school
drama teacher.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
So I just didn't know
what to do.
-You're like, "There's only
one Mr. Frazel out there!
I'm in real trouble."
Thank you, though, on behalf of
all of us, for sharing it.
It couldn't have been easy.
Hopefully it feels better.
-It does.
-Being on the other side of it.
-It's so embarrassing crying.
Sorry.
-That's alright. You know what?
Let's take a break
and we'll come back
and we'll talk about
"Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
I'm so sorry! I can't help it!
I need a tissue.
-We'll get you a tissue.
We'll be right back.